there's definitely a hair in the salad I
hate school lunch every day pretty much
I will love school lunch full lunch was
kind of like a little thing for me
Keitha it's like at separation it has
that really nice cheap pizza flavor that
I made yeah I mean if I was a kid I'd
probably eat this chicken nuggets what
the hell is this dude these beans come
with it what kid likes chick peas
chicken McNuggets aren't naturally good
things and these are terrible versions
of chicken McNuggets everyone should
revolt against this it is horrible
it tastes like something you sweep up
off a floor with a heavy broom there
really don't take much risk with the
flavor on these things mm-hmm is that me
Thanksgiving dinner lunch this turkey
looks like it was roasted last year you
would expect the gravy to do Papa this
is fancy
the gravy looks like that I'm really
ashamed to say that I like this not that
big I know it's bad I know it's bad for
me but I love it why am i tasting gym
mats teriyaki chicken
it looks like dog food who already
doesn't smell great the rice looks like
maybe it's even brown rice like it could
be like a healthy rice never cut an
orange slice oh my chicken teriyaki
that's not a normal thing could be dog
food can't really taste the chicken
teriyaki sauce is dull at best I feel
like I've gotten super old that I'm on
the side of like the school district
being like this is your dessert this is
this is just a gas station burrito and
not even a good gas station burrito I
feel like they had these when I was in
school for sure okay
oh my god it says say no to drugs on the
back what they don't they definitely
don't sell these in 7-eleven then